alors des mères qui appelle l'armée en
renfort un programme chargé dans les
prochaines heures pour l'exécutif avec
un conseil de défense sanitaire à
l'elysée demain suivi le plusieurs
consultations des membres du
gouvernement est la situation est tendue
on revient on y revient tout de suite
avec nos invités et pour en parler nous
sommes avec denis barriol maire de
genilac bonsoir avec vous karim
khelfaoui médecins généralistes bonsoir
alors donnez barriol on vient de le voir
vous vous réclamez avec 20 autres élus
de la loire des moyens sanitaires
militaire le directeur général de la
rs10 comprendre votre inquiétude mais il
assure la situation est maîtrisée alors
qu'on est il dans les hôpitaux de votre
région quels sont les remontées que vous
vous avez beaucoup d'inquiétude avec le
mes collègues de la vallée du gier nous
sommes dans sa tt métropole donc ça fait
plusieurs jours maintenant de l'eau
pendant des chiffres inquiétants et
négatifs que qu'au niveau national
beaucoup ont relayé et nous apprenons
que la vallée du gic et vaincre est une
commune qui font partie de ce petit
métropole sont particulièrement touchés
forcément il ya une inquiétude très
forte des mers et lors de notre dernière
réunion en comité syndical cette
inquiétude a fait naître l'idée d'un
courrier à des tas pour demander des
moyens supplémentaires
notre idée en fait c'est d'anticiper
c'est pas la gestion d'aujourd'hui même
sur celle qui a détendu qu'elle est
complexe
c'était pour anticiper un besoin besoins
à venir peut-être une démarche très
positive avec une peur la critique mais
vraiment dans l'anticipation
justement à propos d' anticipation karim
khelfaoui je rappelle que vous êtes
médecin généraliste par rapport vous à
ce que vous observez la question d'un
reconfirmant aujourd'hui on n'a plus le
choix
aujourd'hui on se retrouve au pied du
mur puisque ça fait
six mois que le gouvernement avait tout
le temps pour préparer une deuxième
vague mais qui n'ont absolument rien
préparé et en partie qu'ils n'ont
absolument pas préparés l'aval
c'est-à-dire qu'ils se sont concentrés
sur l'amour le fait de d'une manière un
peu prétentieuse de dire qu'ils allaient
suffisamment casser les chaînes de
contamination avec le système de traçage
qu'ils allaient limiter les
contaminations avec des mesures
liberticides qu'on a vu dans les bars
les restos les couvre feux etc
on voit qu absolument rien n'a marché
puisque en réalité n'ont aucune prise
sur les contaminations elle-même a
priori parce que déjà ils ne s'occupent
pas des contaminations qui se passe en
lien avec le travail à l'école dans les
entreprises dans les universités ou dans
les transports en commun il fait de ne
pas voir le problème fn et de rejeter la
faute sur les français et aujourd'hui
ils n'ont pas préparé la vallée on a un
premier ministre qui nous dit que ce qui
soulagerait l'hôpital finalement ce
serait de ne pas tomber malade mais de
qui on se moque aujourd'hui en réalité
c'était à eux de préparer sa de
renforcer l'hôpital on a président la
république qui au mois de juillet nous a
expliqué que l'hôpital était prêt pour
une deuxième vague et on se rend compte
à quel point c'est absolument faux
encore une fois parce qu'il fallait un
plan d'embauchés massives
il ne suffisait pas de dire on va
augmenter de 130 euros les salaires 1140
euros
c'était pas ça qu'on a de bons temps
c'était d'un plan d'embauchés massives
et aujourd'hui ils mentent à nouveau en
disant qu'il n'y a pas les compétences
dans le pays qu'il n'ya pas les enfants
nés alors qu'en réalité ne serait ce que
pour les infirmiers il ya là plus de
150000 qui sont dans des missions
d'intérim ou de remplacement et qui ne
veulent plus aller à l'hôpital à cause
des conditions de travail donc c'était
là dessus qu'il fallait le faire et
aujourd'hui on dit on ne veut pas que
les gens on nous allons injustifiée plus
des mesures liberticides en dix ans mais
nous devons pas nous ne voulons pas que
les gens et en réanimation mais moi non
plus je veux pas qu'ils aillent en
réanimation mais la réalité il faut
faire avec c'est qu'ils y bokole quand
il le vaudois qui sont malades
moi non plus je le paquet de guerre dans
le monde je veux qu'on éradique la
pauvreté et j'aimerais avoir un
gouvernement compétent mais il faut
faire avec un principe de réalité il
fallait augmenter les lits et ça fait
des mois qu'il fallait le faire
aujourd'hui on paye le prix de ce qu'ils
ont pas fait justement denis barriol on
n'a rien on entend la colère du docteur
qu'elle fabrique vous rejoignez un petit
peu ce que ce qu'on vient d'entendre
c'est à dire ce manque dans tipi
d'anticipation finalement avant cette
seconde vague qui arrive pas exactement
si je ne partage pas par exemple l'idée
des mesures liberticides vote parce
qu'on en a besoin de prendre les mesures
en fait le tour des marchés les
complémentaires à celles de de l'état
simplement en fait les deux logiques et
non pas une seule logique
je me souviens très bien lors de la
réunion la venue a été une quarantaine
d'élus autour de la table puis a pas que
les mères qui était présent et notre
notre action notre démarche auprès de
madame la préfète était double il avait
certes c'est à qui tu très forte ce qui
remonte du terrain et j'ai besoin de
d'anticipation qui me paraissait
absolument nécessaire par rapport à
l'inquiétude que l'état lui même
d'ailleurs fait peser aussi sur le sur
les yeux et c'est bien logique avec les
chiffres qui tombent régulièrement mais
en même temps pour se situer une partie
la population en tout cas nous dans
notre vallée qui n'avait pas conscience
qu'elles étaient particulièrement
touchés et je pense qu'on s'est rendu
compte mais un décalage entre les
informations que nous pouvions à bois et
les informations qu une partie de la
population pouvait reconnaître et le
fait d'avoir le fait d'être apte à lui
et le club d'être avec vous ce soir par
exemple c'est aussi peut-être une des
logiques en tout cas pour chercher à
avoir des der sar prendre conscience à
notre population je pense qu'il ya ya
opposé les deux logiques hull passionnel
de son dîner à riols
que les gens fassent attention il faut
qu'on l'anticipé moyens vous vous
préparez à quoi ce soir très
concrètement est-ce que vous anticipez
des mesures qui pourraient être prendre
dans les prochaines heures dans les
prochains jours alors nous les communes
les bateaux une commune
il dépend très largement la relier à
nouveau avec nos informations qui sont
très variées puisqu'on avait taillé de
communes qui sont là aussi de très petit
âtre très grande donc on a des moniales
différent mais on a nous relier
médiatement c'est avec nos moyens
ces messages l'attitude d'une part pour
le reste je dirais qu'on fait que ça
depuis marque que sont le maire depuis
mars
ils s'adaptent ils essaient de
stabiliser une situation qui est
instable par essence mais dans la
population on était de leur donner des
repères alors pour une semaine pour 15
jours n'ont fait que ça donc on sera
faire demain s'il ya de nouvelles
décisions qui sont prises on gère cette
angoisse on gère cette instabilité
depuis mars est en tout cas qu'on est
complémentaire avec les textes
comprendre la vie monte les mères contre
l'état de travailler ensemble
docteur comment comprendre la violence
de cette seconde vague s est elle aurait
pu être anticipé quels sont les facteurs
finalement qui ont favorisé ce fort
rebond de l'épidémie les chiffres on le
voit ont bondi à ces derniers jours est
ce qu'elles auraient pu être anticipés
oui c'est évident de nombreux
scientifiques épidémiologistes mettez en
garde d'elle déconfinement contre cette
seconde vague est en réalité en a pas
tenu compte
on a fait comme si tout allait bien
parce qu'il y avait moi
la nation parce que le biais de circuler
dans une population plus jeune et je
suis d'accord avec monsieur le maire il
faut que la population et les conscience
du danger
mais en réalité les français ils ont ils
n'ont fait que ce que le gouvernement
leur a permis de faire c'est le cadre
général
l'environnement dans lequel on a évolué
a été décidée par le gouvernement
et aujourd'hui on paie encore une fois
le manque d'anticipation et ce que je
voulais dire c'est que le ne pas
s'attaquer aux contaminations qui ont
nui au travail c'était une immense faute
qu'on paie aujourd'hui parce que deux
contaminations qui était au départ chez
les plus jeunes dans l'été on a très
vite disséminés cette contamination dans
d'autres tranches d'âge parce que les
gens ne sont pas rencontrés que dans lé
cadre privé sinon on aurait vu les
effets des mesures qui ont été prises
sur les bars les restos les salles de
sport et les couvre feu mais il y en a
aucun c'est bien que au départ il y
avait un problème avec des
contaminations au travail notamment à
l'école et qu'on n'a pas tenu compte
le gouvernement a fait comme si ça
n'existait pas et a même expliqué aux
français que c'était en réalité le soir
quand il était fatigué et qu'il veut
baisser leur vigilance qui se compte
amener ce qui est complètement faux
c'est pierre encore une fois à mon sens
est en réalité il sait le savait parce
que la seule donnée qu'on avait sur les
lieux de contamination
c'était celle de santé publique france
sur les clusters et on sait que la
majorité se faisait au travail mon lien
avec le travail et le gouvernement a
fait comme si ça n'existait pas parce
qu'ils disaient les clusters ça ne
concerne que 10 % des contaminations
donc ils sont partis du principe que les
90% restants n'avait rien à voir
alors qu'en réalité on n'avait aucun
argument scientifique pour dire que
c'est les les quatre les contaminations
restantes se faisait dans des lieux qui
était différent par rapport aux clusters
denis variole aujourd'hui est-ce que
vous êtes favorable à de nouvelles
mesures quitte à ce qu'elle soit du rhin
pour vos administrés qu'est-ce que vous
souhaitez vous aujourd'hui pour juguler
cette cette contamination et faire face
à l'afflux de patients dans les hôpitaux
alors quand on pose ce genre de
questions le moment j'ai coutume de dire
que je ne suis pas médecin donc je n'ai
pas la compétence pour sur les mesures
les pétards qui peut être prise je ne
suis pas spécialiste mais ces questions
moi ce que je peux dire c'est que nous
on doit nous élus à la fois faire passer
des informations qui nous sont donnés
faire en sorte qu'on puisse les décliner
sur le terrain pour qu'elle soit
comprise par la population
sécuriser au mieux les process parce que
c'est pas évident du tout du tout pour
la population et le fait de danty cité
par contre et c'était ça l'objet de
rencontres du courrier qu'on a on avait
envoyé à la presse pour demander des
monnaies par la population après silva
doit y avoir un nouveau ralentissement
s'il le faut pas honnêtement je ne sais
pas où on sera prêt de toute façon pour
la bâtir comme de messages vous prennent
notre population
ça c'est sûr merchet depuis marque en
fait le gouvernement
je suis vert le gouvernement c'est vrai
que disait communiqué en disant voilà on
va s'appuyer sur les acteurs de terrain
aujourd'hui est ce qu'il ya un vrai
dialogue entre l'exécutif et vous
acteurs du terrain est-ce que cela la
chaîne fonctionne bien de communication
là on a des informations qu'il nouvelle
pratique est un gros effort aussi
pourquoi comment une communication ça je
le reconnais ceci dit on te donne peu
d'informations remontant très tôt on est
plutôt dans la déclinaison d'éléments
qui sont qui sont ici nous sont tous ont
demandé françois sait pas qui me gêne
c'est parce qu'ils aiment parce que
c'est aussi comme ça que loeb se faire
les choses dans les temps par contre il
nous faut qu'on oublie seulement et
c'est ça me gêne énormément une pas
qu'on lui dise de seulement attention
les chiffres sont très graves attention
les courbes sont exponentielles
attention dans votre territoire tet en
conclure que la métropole n'a par contre
on va essayer ça pendant quatre semaines
pendant six semaines
c'est pas possible de rapporter certains
angoisse pêche aux l'élu look où on est
là pour organiser pour être positif mais
on ne peut pas porter une angoisse plus
s'il n'y a pas derrière on a
exceptionnel si on nous dit tous les
jours que la situation chez nous est
exceptionnel docteur khelfaoui le
gouvernement avait misé 1 sur sa
stratégie des tests avec ce fameux
triptyque tester isolé tracé pourquoi
selon vous et bien ça n'a pas permis de
juguler
la propagation du coronavirus pour
plusieurs raisons et elles sont trois en
fait on n'a ni tester correctement ni
isoler correctement ni tracé
correctement et en réalité la politique
de traçage était voué à l'échec depuis
le départ on a testé de manière
absolument chaotique depuis le début et
la seule variable en fait qui
intéressait le gouvernement c'est de
pouvoir dire regardez en fait de plus en
plus de tests et ça va 2 c'était le la
variable qui nous donnait à chaque fois
ont fait plus d'un million thèse par
semaine mais c'était pas ça qu'il
fallait faire c'était en réalité testé
dans les zones où il y avait une forte
densité de population où le virus
circule et fortement dans les ont dans
les écoles de sacy reculé fortement dans
les endroits où ça circule et fortement
fallait cibler il fallait cibler et par
contre à chaque fois ne pas attendre
justement qu'on est impatient et qu'on
ait le temps de faire un traçage qui
prenaient du temps parce qu'il fallait
qu'il aille voir le même ça parce qu il
fallait qu ensuite assurance maladie le
contact etc etc
mais en réalité dès qu'il en avait eu un
cas positif avec des cas positifs à des
endroits là il fallait engager un
dépistage de masse dans ce lieu un
dépistage de masse ce n'est pas comme je
n'ai entendu de la bouche du ministre
on va tester toute la population tout le
temps c'est on va déguster à chaque fois
qu'il ya des endroits où c'est
intéressant de le faire toute la
population concernée c'est ça qu'il
fallait faire le traçage c'est pareil on
nous a fait tout un cinéma sur ce
traçage en réalité même le conseil
constitutionnel a dit que effectivement
cédé une atteinte à nos libertés
individuelles et au secret médical et
aujourd'hui on se retrouve avec une
situation où en réalité dans 75% des cas
on arrive pas
cas à un autre donc on a pas trace t on
n'arrive pas à remonter les chefs de
contamination et l' isolement
il n'a jamais été une quelque chose
d'obligatoire
c'est à dire il ya plein de pays où on a
décidé que mais on a les réquisitionner
les hôtels et on allait effectivement
d'isoler les malades
là c'est pas le cas là elle était en
allemand n'a compté sur le fait que les
gens allaient le faire ce qui est on
peut compter sur eux parce qu'ils sont
quand même intelligent mais en dehors de
ça et qu'ils ont continué à contaminer
leurs familles leurs foyers qui des fois
je n'avais pas toutes les informations
dont continuer à sortir et continua
continue à contaminer du monde
donc en réalité le fameux le tester
isolé tracé n'a jamais été en reste ont
perdu donc merci docteur karim khelfaoui
je rappelle que vous êtes médecin
généraliste
merci à vous également denis barriol
maire de génilac merci à tous les deux
d'avoir accepté notre invitation alors